Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir sitzen hier vor dem Salon.
Und wir sprechen über Peter Sloterdijk gleich.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, was du dazu zu sagen hast, aber lass mich erst dir eine Frage stellen.
Hast du mitbekommen, dass Joe Biden seinen Sohn Hunter begnadigt hat?
Habe ich.
Und?
Du hast geschrieben, der König greift ein oder so?
Ja.
Genau, der König. Also ist nicht mehr Präsident zu nennen, finde ich angemessen.
Und wie soll ich sagen, ich habe jetzt das Jahr mit dem Thema Familie verbracht
und für mich liegt es auf der Hand und nicht nur ist es nicht unerklärlich,
sondern ich brauche gar keine weitere Erklärung.
Natürlich begnadigst du, wenn das in deiner Macht steht, deinen Sohn,
wenn der Tyrann vor der Tür steht.
Aber das ist ja jetzt eine Aussage, die jetzt darauf abzieht,
dass er seinen Sohn vor Trump beschützt.
Aber es ist ja eher so, dass Hunter Biden vor der Justiz geschützt wird.
Ja, aber die Justiz ist ab Januar Trump.
Ja, aber die Justiz hat ja auch schon gegen Hunter vorher ermittelt und ich
meine, es liegt ja sehr viel offen.
Und kann man nicht eher sagen, Joe Biden agiert genauso wie Trump,
beziehungsweise wie wir glauben, Trump wird reagieren?
Also die Ankündigung, die Trump ja schon gemacht hat, die natürlich massenmedial
keinen Widerhalt fand, weil sie
in den Kanälen stattfand, wo sie gehört wird, ist, die Leute, die am 6.
Januar 2021 die Demokratie stürmten, werden alle begnadigt.
Also wir werden hunderte Begnadigungen sehen.
Ja, das mag alles sein. Nur glaube ich, dass es ja völlig falsch ist,
wenn man jetzt von demokratischer Seite das auch genauso macht.
Es ist ja nicht genau so, sondern da ist ja eine klare und auch nur sehr einheitliche
Familienbande, während Trump einfach durch die Bank jetzt… Ja.
Aber Trump hat ja auch, das war ja immer der Vorwurf der Demokraten,
dass Trump seine Leute da reinnimmt und irgendwelche Familienseilschaften,
unternehmerische Seilschaften fortsetzt in sein präsidiales Amt.
Und das ist ja etwas, was jetzt Joe Biden auch macht.
Deswegen finde ich, kann man jetzt nicht mit Doppelstandards hier agieren,
sondern muss einfach sagen, nein, jeder nutzt das instrumentell für sich, wie es ihm gerade hilft.
Und da gibt es für mich dann vielleicht einen qualitativen Unterschied in der
Intensität, wie das Trump... möglicherweise ausüben wird, aber ich finde,
dass wir grundsätzlich aber sagen können, dass beide Seiten das machen.
Also ich sag mal so, Donald Trump hat in seiner allerersten,
oder seiner ersten Präsidentschaft,
Das Recht auf Begnadigung schon auf Jared Kushners Vater angewandt.
Der ist damals von Chris Christie mitverurteilt worden, der war damals der Staatsanwalt.
So, das heißt, dieses Begnadigung innerhalb von Familienbünden ist schon etabliert, bevor Biden jetzt.
Zeigt aber eine sehr antimoderne Ausprägung, denn normalerweise bedeutet Moderne,
dass man eben nicht mehr diese Familienbande in die Politik einführt,
sondern die Familie ist eine Sache des Privatlebens und dort hat es zu verbleiben.
Und wenn man jetzt aber anfängt, so zu regieren, dann sind wir eigentlich wieder
in feudalen Zeiten angekommen, in aristokratischen Zeiten.
Und deswegen glaube ich, wird das mit Trump sicherlich nochmal schlimmer werden.
Aber ich finde, dass die Demokraten ihr Recht, Trump zu kritisieren,
verwirken, wenn sie sich selbst ähnlich verhalten.
Also wir haben in diesem Podcast schon etabliert sozusagen in der Aussprache
über dieses Supreme Court Urteil, dass Trump oder den amerikanischen Präsidenten,
aber Trump wird halt namentlich genannt in dem Urteil,
über das Gesetz, über die Verfassung, über alles hebt. Ja.
Von dem er das Supreme Court meinte, das ist zu nah, der Präsident muss drüber
stehen, er braucht mehr Freiheit, dieses Rule of Law gilt für alle,
aber eben abseits des Königs.
Also Rule of Law ist sozusagen Rule of the King.
In deren Sicht, ja, der amerikanische Präsident steht über dem Gesetz und über der Justiz.
In Sachen Begnadigungsrechte galt das schon immer und galt auch für alle Gouverneure.
Ich weiß noch, damals als Arnold Schwarzenegger das Amt verließ,
hat ja plötzlich in Graz oder so die Stadt entschieden, wir nennen unser Stadion
nicht mehr nach ihm, weil er da eben Begnadigungsrechte nicht gewährt hat.
Muss man ja auch mal so sehen, nicht gewährt hat. So, in deren Sicht,
was das Felder angeht, ist runter und drüber.
Nur, und jetzt, ich habe auf YouTube ja für die letzten auch schon Stefan immer
mit harten Thesen, ich stelle jetzt eine Hypothese auf.
Donald Trump, oder nur weil Donald Trump der nächste Präsident ist,
hat Biden sein eigenes Versprechen gebrochen und gesagt, ich bediene mich dieses
Rechts, obwohl ich eigentlich als Präsident gelten wollte, der sich noch eingliedert.
Wäre jetzt Kamala Harris die nächste Präsidentin geworden, hätte er diese Begnadigung
nicht ausgesprochen. Das ist meine These.
Das können wir natürlich ganz schwer überprüfen.
Genau, können Sie gar nicht überprüfen.
Ich halte das für ein bisschen fadenscheinig, ehrlich gesagt,
weil ich doch hier sehe, dass die Demokraten einmal mehr, das ist ja nicht das
erste Mal, doch alles nutzen und instrumentell für sich gebrauchen, wie es ihnen passt.
Wenn das dann andere tun, dann ist der Alarm groß. Wenn Trump das macht,
ist es besonders schlimm. Und das ist, glaube ich, ein wiederkehrendes Prinzip, das wir sehen.
Wenn Sarah Wagenknecht sagt, die da auf der Domplatte Frauen belästigt haben,
Silvester, die haben ihr Gastrecht verwirkt, dann ist ein ganz großer Aufschreiter zu Recht.
Wenn aber Grüne davon reden, dass wer sich hier falsch verhält,
sein Gastrecht verwirkt hat, sagt man, naja, wunderbar.
Und das ist eine neue Sache. Also es ist immer die Frage, nur noch wer spricht
und nicht mehr, was eigentlich der Fall ist.
Also ich würde ja sagen, Handlungen sind gleichermaßen zu bewerten, egal wer sie tut.
Und Aussagen, die getroffen werden, sind Aussagen, die bewertet werden müssen.
Aber es ist jetzt immer entscheidend.
Sagt der eine, wir müssen abschieben, ist der von der AfD, dann ist das schlimm.
Sagt jemand aus der Grünen Partei, wir müssen abschieben, dann ist das eine
Frage der Vernunft und jetzt müssen wir auch mal pragmatisch sein.
Und das ist fundamental falsch und das verschiebt sich alles gerade in eine
solche Richtung, dass wir nur noch gucken, wer spricht und dann ist es völlig
egal, was am Ende das Resultat ist,
sondern wenn das Resultat dasselbe ist wie bei einem Rechten,
bei einer linken Politik,
wenn alles gleich ist, dann können wir eigentlich an einen Punkt kommen,
wo wir dann sagen, dann bewerten wir nur noch, weil uns die Person gefällt oder nicht gefällt.
Und dann unterstützen wir mal rechte Politik, weil das eine nette Person ist,
die die vorträgt, im Kuschelpoli Rubel-Horbeck oder wir sind dagegen,
weil das von einer wütenden Alice Weidel vorgetragen wird.
Und ich bin dagegen, ich möchte Handlungen und Aussagen nach dem bewerten,
für was sie stehen und was sie bezwecken und nicht wer sie spricht.
Also wir haben in Deutschland auch ein Begnadigungsrecht, das zum Beispiel bei
der Auslieferung des Tiergartenmörders nicht angewandt wurde,
sondern da musste Marco Buschmann aufwendige Argumentation machen.
Das heißt, selbst da, wo wir erstens, wie du, argumentieren und sagen,
ist das nicht total anachronistisch und es gibt es trotzdem und dann haben wir
sogar den Fall und dann haben wir Leute in Verantwortung, die es nicht anwenden.
Also das gibt es bei uns und wir sehen in Amerika den Gegenteil.
So im Sinne von, ja klar, ist ja sein Sohn, er will ihn halt schützen,
er verwendet das einfach.
Aber für die Bewertung dieser Maßstäbe, so klar die moralischen und juristischen
Argumentationen sind, lege ich jetzt nochmal den Fokus auf Abwarten,
wie die Maßstäbe uns in einem oder zwei Jahren scheinen, denn,
Ja, Trump kommt jetzt ins Amt und er hat mit diesem Project 2025 sozusagen eine
Ankündigung, von der er sich so ein bisschen freisprach, aber wir wissen alle, wo das herkommt.
Und ja, 900 Seiten, da steht alles drin. Eben nicht alles.
Wir haben ein 180 Days Playbook, so heißt es, das unveröffentlicht blieb.
Das hat dieser Vogue da einfach geschrieben und es blieb unveröffentlicht.
Und da stehen diese Sachen drin, von denen ich jetzt schon sprach,
also dass man natürlich dieses große Zeichen vielleicht sogar direkt in der Antrittsrede sagt,
dass man natürlich hier diese Begnadigung für die Kapitolstürmer ausspricht
und dann sind wir qualitativ und quantitativ in anderem Fahrwasser.
Also jetzt einfach sagen, ja der Joe Biden hat eine Person und seinen Sohn,
weil dann geht es nicht nur um eine Person und auch nicht um irgendwie dann
doch nachvollziehbare, wenn auch natürlich unverständliche Familienbünde,
in der Hinsicht, ich habe Verständnis dafür, dass er seinen Sohn jetzt in Sicherheit bringt.
Ja, ich kann das auch verstehen. Ich glaube, jeder kann das sofort verstehen,
dass er das tut und man kann sich fragen, würde man das tun.
Die Sache ist nur, wenn man dann plötzlich diese neuen Standards für sich anlegt,
dann muss man natürlich auch sehen, wie man den Gegner noch beurteilen kann,
beziehungsweise wie man ihn noch kritisieren kann.
Denn das ist natürlich ein gefundenes Fressen jetzt für Trump zu sagen,
na seht her, die machen das ja noch viel schlimmer.
Ich will noch ein Thema aufrufen, das wir das letzte Mal ausführlich besprochen
haben, das Thema Männlichkeit, Weiblichkeit.
Und möchte sagen, dass ich den Eindruck habe, dass wir momentan vom Feminismus
relativ wenig hören, im Sinne von, der Feminismus müsste sich eigentlich auch um die Männer kümmern.
Und ich will dir ein klares Beispiel dafür geben. Die scheidende US-Regierung
hatte ja in den vergangenen Tagen einen tollen Vorschlag für die Wehrfähigkeit der Ukraine.
Nämlich sollte die Ukraine doch bitte, so kam aus Kreisen von Joe Biden an die
Presse, das Wehrdienstalter senken.
Und zwar von 25 auf 18 Jahre. Also man wollte jetzt, dass die auch die Männer,
die ganz jungen Männer verheizen.
Die ukrainischen Stimmen, die dann meistens anonym zitiert wurden,
sagten, nee, nee, wir brauchen ja auch diese jungen Männer, die müssen ja auch
später Kinder zeugen und wir brauchen die für die Wirtschaft.
Das heißt, der Mann ist nur noch eine Verfügungsmasse.
Besonders albern oder eigentlich verrückt fand ich,
das Spiegel Online genau diese Meldung von der Heruntersetzung des Wehralters
da mit einem Foto gezeigt hat, auf dem man eine Soldatin sah.
Ja, von hinten mit einem Zopf. Es ging aber hier nicht um die Frauen,
die eingezogen werden, sondern es geht um Männer, die einfach als eine Verfügungsmasse
da sind, über die jetzt die Regierungen entscheiden und die Journalisten hierzulande
sagen dann noch, ja ist aber auch genau richtig.
Und das finde ich wirklich erstaunlich, dass sich dagegen...
Kein großer Protestwert, dass da mal irgendwelche Stimmen laut werden.
Wir haben wahnsinnig viele Diskussionen darüber und zu Recht haben wir die darüber,
was eigentlich geschieht, wenn diese Abtreibungsrechte beschnitten werden,
was den Frauen damit in den USA angetan wird.
Darum kümmert man sich vielfach, auch hier in den deutschen Medien und Deutsche,
auch diese marktkonformen Feministen, also Passmann, Kebekus und Co.
Haben das gerne als Thema, aber niemals würden diese und andere ansprechen,
wie eigentlich die Männer seit Jahren jetzt einfach nur als Menschenmaterial
behandelt werden, von dem man sagen kann, naja die ab 25 die müssen sterben,
die anderen müssen noch nicht sterben.
Und ähnliches finden wir auch in der Diskussion um den Nahostkrieg,
wo man auch die ganze Zeit sagt, Frauen und Kinder, Frauen und Kinder, Frauen und Kinder.
So als seien diese Männer, die dort sterben, alle Hamas oder was.
Nein, natürlich auch nicht, sondern da sind auch ganz, ganz viele Männer einfach
Opfer, keine Täter, sondern sind einfach Opfer.
Aber wir haben eine totale Fokussierung darauf, dass man entweder über Frauen
oder Kinder spricht, aber dass da
hunderttausende Männer sich gegenseitig abschlachten müssen auf Feldern.
Das ist nicht das Thema, sondern da sagt man noch, ja, müsste man nochmal drüber
nachdenken, vielleicht das Alter ein bisschen heruntersetzen,
mal schauen. Und dann kommt vielleicht noch die Diskussion, ja wir müssen ihnen
bessere Waffen geben, dann kämpfen die auch gerne.
So als wenn man ihnen bessere Waffen gibt, würde dann niemand mehr sterben,
was auch nicht der Fall ist.
Und ich sehe da wirklich einen Mangel an Feminismus in dem Maß nämlich,
dass man hier einfach sagt, der Mann ist nicht so viel wert.
Und eigentlich bedeutet Feminismus ja, die Gleichberechtigung der Geschlechter
bedeutet zu sagen, dass jeder gleich viel wert ist.
Also, wo soll man anfangen? Beim Thema Kämpfen, dass Frauen da nicht in Betracht
gezogen werden mitzukämpfen, hat ja sozusagen mehrfache,
Entweder konkrete Diskriminierung oder merkwürdige Blicke auf das weibliche
Geschlecht zur Ursache.
Nämlich, dass man zum Beispiel sagen könnte, da steckt ja schon drin,
ah ja, Frauen werden eh nicht so als kampfbreit, kräftig oder wie auch immer.
Das, was gefragt ist auf dem Felde, liefern Frauen nicht, also sind sich schon mal außen vor.
Zweitens braucht man Frauen insbesondere zu Hause, denn beim Mann reicht es
ihm drei Wochen Fronturlaub zu geben für Nachwuchs, die Frau braucht man einfach durchgehend.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, wir sehen jetzt eine politische Diskussion,
bei denen Männer als Verfügungsmasse gelten.
Also Verfügungsmasse ist der Grundbegriff des politischen Blicks auf Frauen
der letzten 150 Jahre. Mit dem besonderen Fokus, dass man, wenn ich jetzt sage,
im politischen Grundbegriff es aber privat ausgelebt hat.
Also noch 2019, kurz vor Weihnachten stand der Bundespräsident bei der Kohleverabschiedung,
hat die letzten Männer aus dem Stollen mit Handschlag begrüßt,
sie haben das Steigerlied gesungen.
Und dann wurde den unbesungenen und auch nicht anwesenden tapferen Helden,
Ehefrauen gedankt, weil während die Männer immer noch sich aussuchen konnten,
wo sie arbeiten, in welchem Stollen, der Arbeitgeber war so ein bisschen variabel,
also man konnte von Essen nach was weiß ich wohin ziehen oder so,
war für die Frauen völlig klar, du heiratest mit 18 und ab dann ist das dein Mann.
Und alle moralischen, juristischen und was auch immer, stürzt über dich hinein
und schreibt dieses Schicksal fest.
Das heißt, wenn du jetzt sagst, wo ist der Protest?
Männer jetzt an die Front müssen mit 18, würde ich sagen. Also wir können jetzt
nicht den Frauen abverlangen, dass sie da auch noch für die Männer...
Oh doch, oh doch. Denn es gibt eine große männliche Solidarität mit den Frauen,
die für Gleichberechtigung eingetreten sind. Überall in der Politik.
Nee.
Doch.
Das ist keine große Solidarität.
Also bitte.
Friedrich Merz steht auf der Bühne und sagt...
Also jetzt komm, jetzt musst du aber fair bleiben. Also wenn du jetzt mit Friedrich
Merz ankommst, der war natürlich nicht gemeint.
Aber wenn ich mir jetzt ansehe, was zum Beispiel grüne oder linke Politiker,
Männer, auch getan haben für die Emanzipation der Frau, die entsprechenden Gesetze
auf den Weg gebracht haben,
solidarisch mit den Frauen waren, es ist nicht so, als sei den Männern,
allen Männern jetzt gerade, ich spreche hier von der Gegenwart,
das Schicksal der Frauen egal, das ist nicht der Fall.
Es sind zu wenige Männer, die sich anschließen. Nein, lass es mich jetzt sagen.
Wir reden hier auch von wirklich qualitativ unterschiedlichen Dingen.
Wir reden hier von einer Steinkohlezeit, die jetzt lange schon zurückliegt.
Und wir sprechen jetzt hier von einer Gegenwart, bei der es zwar einen Gender
Pay Gap noch gibt und wir sprechen auch von der Care Arbeit,
die immer noch zu Lasten von Frauen geht.
Aber wir sprechen hier auch von Männern, die zum Sterben abkommandiert werden.
Und dass da sich kein feministischer Protest dagegen wehrt, dass man einfach
nur sagt, das ist jetzt einfach so.
Dass das überhaupt nicht als Sensibilisierung eingelernt ist,
zeigt mir auch, dass der Feminismus da wirklich versagt, wo er nicht auch den
Mann in einen emanzipatorischen Kampf inkludiert.
Und das wahre auch eigentlich immer eine feministische Idee.
Das kann man zum Beispiel bei Simone Weil nachlesen.
Aber.
Man kann jetzt kritisieren, dass die Frauen nicht an der Seite der Männer stehen,
wenn die 18- bis 25-Jährigen jetzt auch an die Front müssen.
Ja generell müsste man auch, wir haben hier eine Wehrpflichtsdebatte,
da bekommen jetzt Leute Briefe geschickt, Männer und Frauen.
Die Männer, die müssen antworten und haben mit Strafen zu rechnen,
wenn sie nicht antworten.
Die Frauen können antworten, müssen aber nicht.
Ich bin jetzt nicht dafür, die Frauen da gleich zu berechtigen,
weil in dem Sinne, dass wir sagen, jetzt sollen alle in den Krieg,
sondern man müsste eigentlich aus einer feministischen Perspektive heraus in
eine pazifistische Protestaktion übergehen.
Und genau das findet aber nicht statt, weil man sagt, es sind ja nur Männer.
Ich akzeptiere das alles und verstehe das Problem.
Ich will eine überraschende kleine Wendung in die Diskussion,
denn ich habe ja schon gesagt, uns fehlen Grundbegriffe.
Das Wort feministisch, finde ich schon mal, führt auf den falschen Fuß,
weil es zu sehr die Frau in den Mittelpunkt stellt, wo es ja eigentlich um Grundsätzliches geht.
Deswegen mal ein konkretes Bild. Bei der Frage, wo ist nicht der Protest,
sondern die Unterstützungsbekundung?
Wir haben eine Situation, in der lauter Männer gerade unter sich ausmachen,
wer der nächste Kanzler wird, weil sie wissen, du kannst ja eh nur A,
B, C oder D wählen, komplizierter ist ja das politische System nicht und allen
diesen Parteien stehen Männer vor.
Also entweder man wählt Merz, Scholz oder wen auch immer.
Und in diesem politischen System wurde kürzlich Kevin Kühnert aussortiert.
Kevin Kühnert hat quasi die Botschaft gemacht und zwar auch nur per Brief,
ich bin psychisch krank, was das Signal ist für alle, der ist ab jetzt schwach,
den sortieren wir aus. So.
Er hat keinerlei Unterstützung von Frauen, keinerlei Unterstützung von Männern
bekommen, sondern es war allenfalls das typische, wir bekunden mal kurz unsere
Sympathie und so weiter.
Und das Bild, das mir wichtig ist, ist ja, können wir uns ein politisches System
vorstellen, in dem beispielsweise jemand wie Kevin Kühnert sagt,
ich bin psychisch krank und damit meine ich nicht, ich melde mich ab.
Ich ziehe mich zurück und stehe nie wieder für Gespräche zur Verfügung,
sondern ich bin psychisch krank, aber ich bin ja trotzdem clever und habe bewiesen,
dass ich politische Ideen nicht nur vorbringe, sondern dann auch über Telefonketten, was auch immer,
die Jusos für eine Bundestagswahl aufstellen kann.
Jetzt wissen wir ja nicht, wie gut oder schlecht es ihm geht,
das finde ich jetzt komisch, darüber zu spekulieren, was ich aber feststellen kann.
Ich dachte doch, dass Kevin Kühnert in einem System, das nur einer Idee folgt,
nämlich der Repräsentation,
einfach sagt, ich bin psychisch krank, so wie 30 Prozent aller Studierenden
zum Beispiel oder drohend 50 Prozent aller alleinerziehenden Mütter und wir
brauchen mich trotzdem in der Politik,
bitte sortiert mich nicht aus.
Und es ist aber völlig klar in Deutschland, wenn man sagt, ich bin psychisch krank.
Switchen alle Journalisten und alle politischen Kollegen sofort um.
Ja, wer macht dann den Posten jetzt? Ach, der Mirsch, ja cool.
Der war ja schon immer stolz und stark und so und konnte als Mann einfach glänzen.
So und dann gehen alle ins Tagesgeschäft über. So und ich möchte jetzt,
ja sozusagen an den Grenzbereichen in anderen Ländern ist Krieg und dort wird
jetzt auf amerikanische Empfehlungen, die Ukrainer sind ja dagegen,
also ich glaube nicht, dass es dazu kommt, aber der lokale Protest.
Dass man überhaupt es wagt, als demokratische Partei einen solchen Vorschlag
zu machen, nimmt doch einfach mal noch die jungen Männer dazu.
Ist doch ein Skandal, wir können doch nicht nur uns darüber aufregen,
dass die Republikaner sich anmaßen, in die Ehebetten hinein zu regieren.
Wenn die Amerikaner, die Demokraten sich zugleich anmaßen zu sagen,
schickt doch mal eure 18-Jährigen zum Sterben los.
Und da gibt es keinen großen Protest und sagt man, ja ist halt Krieg und sind
nur Männer. Das ist doch meine Diskussion.
Die ich hier führe.
Das andere ist ja eine Frage von, wie weit ist die Gesellschaft bereit,
Vulnerabilität zuzulassen, warum muss eigentlich die Politik immer nur eine
Politik der Stärke sein und der Durchsetzungskraft, warum gibt es nicht auch andere Modi,
die wichtig wären, da stimme ich ja vollkommen zu.
Nur sehen wir jetzt gerade, dass hier einfach mal über die Köpfe von hunderttausenden
junger Menschen Männer hinweg entschieden wird, wie sie zu agieren haben und
in den Opferaufzählungen beim Naostrieg, achtet mal bitte drauf,
fällt es auf, es sind Frauen und Kinder, die genannt werden und selten geht
es um Männer, weil sie offenbar unter einem Generalverdacht stehen,
dass wenn sie eine Rakete abbekommen in Gaza oder im Libanon,
dann werden sie wahrscheinlich schon zu den Terroristen gehören.
Und das ist auch eine völlig falsche Perspektive darauf.
Absolut, alles richtig. Ich will nur...
Keine Ahnung, ich will es auch nicht zu in die Länge ziehen,
aber mir geht es um diesen Punkt, der sicherlich vielen sehr naiv scheint.
Aber wenn jemand sagt, ab jetzt sollen auch die unter 25-Jährigen kämpfen,
will ich, dass sofort gefragt wird, wieso soll überhaupt jemand kämpfen? Seid ihr bescheuert?
Es geht jetzt nicht um die 18-25-Jährigen, um die geht es jetzt gerade konkret,
das verstehe ich, aber diese ganze Idee, dass überhaupt jemand ein öffentliches,
bespielbares, medial bespielbares Feld vorfindet, wo man sagen kann,
nee, wir brauchen nicht nur die 26-Jährigen, sondern auch die 23-Jährigen,
muss dem grundsätzlich eine Absage erteilt werden.
Richtig. Und da müsste es eigentlich, und da gibt es auch eine pazifistische
Tradition im Feminismus, Stimmen geben, die da laut werden.
Wenn man aber Feminismus in den Medien, und ich meine jetzt nicht die wirklich
feministischen Aktivisten, sondern ich meine die, die eben schon genannten,
die Medienhanseln, die auftreten.
Wenn die nur noch sich darüber artikulieren, ob eine Botox-Spritze feministisch
ist oder empowernd ist oder nicht,
dann sind wir einfach an einem Punkt angelangt, wo die eigentlich großen feministischen
Fragen, nämlich die der wirklichen Gleichberechtigung, nicht mehr stattfinden.
Und diese Karnevalisten-Aufführungen erleben wir tagtäglich,
während das Eigentliche nicht mehr angesprochen wird.
Ich meine, wir haben jetzt eine Situation politisch, in der ein Obermacker gegen
eine Banane ankämpft, wer länger durchhält, Christian Lindner.
Und er dann in seiner Partei rumfragt, wer steht mir denn zur Seite und dann
sagt Agnes Strack-Zimmermann ab, weil sie weiß, über ihren belizistischen Scheiß
die letzten drei Jahre hat sie sich in die Pole-Position gebracht,
die freie Demokratie, von denen sie sagt,
also freie Demokratie, nicht mal die freien irgendwas und so,
sondern die freie Demokratie kann von mir angeführt werden.
Und das ist einfach grotesk. Ich lehne das alles ab. Also ich bin wirklich, das ist alles Schrott.
Das ist übrigens auch für nächstes Jahr.
Du hast es ja eben schon beim Thema Begnadigung.
Ja, das, was wir jetzt in Amerika sehen, ist nicht nur in Amerika scheiße,
sondern es ist auch hier scheiße.
Also wenn wir was sehen, was in Amerika einfach gar nicht geht,
dann müssen wir einfach sagen, sorry, das geht hier auch nicht.
Wenn ich Friedrich Merz sehe, wir lesen nachher diesen Text von Livia Gerster,
wo sie mal den fritzischen Feminismusfundus zum Thema Frauen und so weiter durchgeht.
Das ist grotesk. Solche Leute, das ist nicht akzeptabel.
Die müssen alle vom Hof gejagt werden. Und da muss man sich,
es gibt dann zwei Möglichkeiten.
Ja, man kann protestieren, aber man kann auch sich sehr offensichtlich,
sehr explizit einfach abmelden von diesem politischen System.
Genau, und auch sich gegen diese Normalisierung richten, indem man sich einfach
sagt, ich höre nicht mehr auf solche Stimmen.
Wenn Paul Ronsheimer oder Micky Beisenherz jetzt einen Auftritt von Friedrich
Merz in der Talkshow sehen und dann sagen, war ein starker Auftritt,
dann muss man einfach sagen, diesen Diskurs canceln wir, damit haben wir nichts
mehr zu tun, lasst den das in ihren Blasen machen, aber man darf es einfach nicht mehr rezipieren.
Ganz genau.
Und da muss man bereitstehen mit den richtigen Sprüchen.
Also das ist einfach die, ich verabschiede mich aus dem politischen System.
Auch bei der Frage, gehst du wählen? Man muss stolz sagen können,
nee, es macht keinen Sinn.
In diesem politischen System gehe ich nicht wählen. Und wenn dann irgendwer
kommt mit, ja, aber dann gewinnt ja die AfD, muss man einfach,
nee, also ich habe zuletzt gesehen, die Wahlbeteiligung stieg und was stieg auch? Die AfD.
Also das muss grundsätzlich jetzt neu gedacht werden. Es geht nicht um die 18-25-Jährigen,
die jetzt auch in den Krieg müssen.
Nee, sollen mal die Älteren oder was kämpfen? Also das ist nicht das Argument.
Und bei der Frage, gehst du wählen, haben wir eine Auswahl?
Also ich sehe Schmerz, Scholz und Merz, das ist keine Auswahl.
Und selbst wenn man feststellt, die SPD schreibt aber ein ganz schön kluges
Zeug ins Programm, die nächste Bundestagsregierung wird aus drei Parteien gebildet.
Selbst wenn die SPD da dabei ist, haben wir doch zuletzt gesehen,
das programmatische Abarbeiten von Wahlprogrammatik endete 300 Tage nach der Wahl.
Die Hälfte der Zeit ging drauf, um einen Koalitionsvertrag zu schreiben,
dann hatten die noch 150 Tage und seitdem ist nichts mehr passiert.
Ich habe im Buch diese Übersicht, familienpolitisch, was alles liegen geblieben
ist, keine Verantwortungsgemeinschaft, keine Solomütter, keine Elternschaftsvereinbarung, gar nichts.
Wir haben das Unterhaltszeug nicht neu geregelt, es ist immer noch,
der Vater geht, zahlt Unterhalt, alles ist geklärt.
Männer bekommen Kinder und ihnen werden ihre biologisch eigentlich zustehenden
Rechte nicht zugestanden.
Nichts. Also wir haben einfach gar keinen Fortschritt. Und von daher,
lasst jetzt einfach die CDU regieren.
In Amerika, lasst einfach Trump regieren. Haben die Demokraten irgendetwas erreicht,
von dem wir sagen, oh, das ist aber top? Null. Also wirklich null.
Aber das letzte Mal hast du noch sehr dafür plädiert, die Frauen in der Linken zu wählen.
Ja, aber die Frauen in der Linken wählt man jetzt einfach nicht,
weil sie das kleinere Übel sind, sondern weil sie eine echte Alternative bilden.
Was bedeutet, für mich ist ganz wichtig, dass sie bei ihrem Tenor bleiben,
einfach zu sagen, was weiß ich, keine Milliardäre, unabhängig davon,
ob sie im Bundestag sind oder nicht.
Ob sie jetzt mit 4% neben dem Bundestag stehen oder mit 7% im Bundestag.
Das spielt gar keine Rolle.
Der Bundestag ist eine andere mediale Bühne, okay.
Aber ich meine, wir hatten eine Bundesministerin für Familien,
die den Bundesminister für Finanzen mit einem,
kann man ja sagen, sie musste ihn erpressen, damit mittwochs bei einer Kabinettsetzung
nicht nur ein Tagespunkt von Tristan Lindner gewünscht, sondern auch ihr Kindergrundsicherung
auf die Tagesordnung kommt.
Also wenn sich selbst im Bundeskabinett gegenseitig erpresst werden muss,
und zwar über die Medien, nicht mal in der direkten Ansprache,
sondern über die Medien.
Man ruft morgens beim Deutschlandfunk an und sagt, das kommt heute nicht auf die Tagesordnung.
Und dann sagt der Dürr, aber wir brauchen das als Wirtschaftswachstumsgesetz,
das ist doch ganz wichtig, wir brauchen noch eine wachsende Wirtschaft.
Dann sagt sie, aber nur mit der Kindergrundsicherung.
Also wenn selbst auf der Ebene Erpressungen stattfinden müssen,
dann ist völlig egal, welche Reden im Bundestag gehalten werden,
welche kleinen Anfragen da gestellt werden und was da sonst passiert.
Ja, ja, das stimmt.
Und deswegen, der Zuspruch für die Linken ist wichtig.
Dass sie jetzt ihren komisches OPA-Programm da fahren mit dieser Silberlockenrakete und so. Okay.
Das interessiert mich null. Also wirklich null.
Obwohl ich das jetzt als Thema auch nicht, ich glaube es ist interessant für
die jetzt finanziell, wenn man nicht in den Bundestag reinkäme,
dann wäre das natürlich eine große Katastrophe auch für sowas wie Rosa-Luxemburg-Stiftung,
da fällt dann eine ganze Infrastruktur weg.
Genau, aber die kann man ja auch genauso gut ersetzen. Ich plädiere hier die,
wie hieß das Buch von Namen, Namen, Namen.
Was haben wir zuletzt zum Thema Machtübernahme und so weiter gelesen?
Semsrott, Arne Semsrott. Der hat auch diesen ganz wichtigen Punkt gemacht,
der uns so ein bisschen naiv und flapsig vorkommt, aber das bessere Leben kann
man schon mal selber leben.
Man muss nicht warten, bis die Politik sagt, das ist unser Angebot.
Gut, aber man braucht ein bisschen Geld, man braucht ein bisschen Geld,
um eine Infrastruktur zu machen.
Aber in Deutschland haben sehr viele Leute Geld. Es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass alle Bürgergeldbänder sind.
Wenn sie es dann an die Richtigen geben, hast du gesehen, dass der Sänger von
Annenwey Kanterreit 95.000 Euro an die Grünen gespendet hat?
Ja, zehn Glückwunsch.
Ja, ich würde sagen, da hätte man sich auch einen schönen Sportwagen von Jaguar kaufen können.
Wurde er nicht von, wie auch immer, Lea Reisner, Cansin Köktürk,
das letzte Mal haben wir sie noch angesprochen, jetzt sind sie plötzlich alle
Direktkandidaten, also es geht jetzt schnell, die kann man durchaus wählen,
man sollte die dann aber dann auch wählen,
dieses ganze taktische, also taktisches wählen, das ist alles schrott,
also wenn jemand in der Politik wählbar ist für euch in eurem Wahlkreis,
der eine gute Idee hat, ich weiß das noch hier, ich kann das nochmal schildern,
Ich habe bei der letzten Bundestagswahl taktisch gewählt, weil ich einen CDU-Kandidaten
verhindern wollte. Ich war ja Grünwähler beim letzten Mal.
Und hier bei mir im Wahlkreis ist ja Nouripour im Wahlkreis.
Und der hatte mit weitem Abstand diesen Wahlkreis gewonnen.
Also ich hätte meine Stimme einfach gleich dem Grünen geben können und ihn nochmal mehr wählen können.
Stattdessen wollte ich einfach einen CDU-Mann verhindern. Das ist doch dumm.
Also das mache ich jetzt nicht mehr.
Wir sprechen heute über Europa. Wir haben das Buch von Peter Sloterdijk dazu gelesen.
Peter Sloterdijk ist ein Philosoph, der wahnsinnig viel gelesen hat, wie wir merken.
Und du hast uns auch einen Denker der Stunde mitgebracht.
Nämlich Milley war bei Lex Friedman zu Gast und erzählt dort wohl auch,
was er so an Lektüren inhaliert.
Ja, ich sag mal so, wenn ich sowas konsumiere, mache ich mir immer sehr viele
Clips. Man weiß ja nie, ist ja gut, das immer schief zu haben.
Ich wollte die beim letzten Mal spielen, aber der Podcast war ja mit 5 Stunden 40 schon sehr lang.
Also dachte ich jetzt, okay, ich bring's heute nochmal mit, weil gerade alle
so viel über Melee reden.
Aber sie reden nicht wirklich über Melee, sondern ich will mich nicht zu viel
aufregen. Aber wir lachen über Amerika, wenn Trump auf der Debattenbühne steht
und sagt, they're eating our cats and dogs.
Und wir wissen alle, das ist so strunzdoof.
Wieso macht er das? Aber die Nachrichten sind voll davon.
Also aufmerksamkeitsmäßig super erfolgreich. Wir hören dann später, ja,
also von, wir haben ja die Clips gespielt, von Bernie Sanders,
der einfach im Podcast sagt, du kannst nicht etwas mit nichts bekämpfen,
weil dann ist selbst das Etwas, da steht jemand und sagt, die essen unsere Hunde
und Katzen raus, Ausländer raus, ja.
Das ist dann eine Botschaft, die verfängt. Haben wir ja gesehen, war mehr als tauglich.
So, und wir haben in Deutschland dasselbe Problem.
Der Cats and Dogs Moment in Deutschland ist, Christian Lindner sitzt bei Mioska
und sagt, wir sollten mehr Millet und Musk wagen.
Das ist Cats and Dogs, ja.
Ja.
Und alle steigen darauf ein.
Weil Lindner schon sehr gut erleben kann, er dreht sich auch immer jetzt von
der Moderatorin weg und blickt direkt in die Kamera.
Das ist auch schon so ein Trump-Move, zu sagen, ich spiele nicht mehr in diesem
System mit, sondern richte mich direkt ans Publikum.
Christian Lindner macht im Grunde das, von
dem ich sagte, das sollte der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk befürchten.
Und ich wünsche es mir auch, dass jemand in Berlin direkt Studio steht und sagt,
Ich weiß, dass sie einen Anzug haben und ich.
Und ich weiß, dass Politik ein sehr seriöses Geschäft ist. Aber die Leute,
die uns verfolgen, sitzen gerade zu Hause und machen Essen.
Sie sind gerade beim Sport, was auch immer.
Sie wollen locker-Talk. Locker-Room-Talk.
Ja, beziehungsweise wollen sie auch andere Themen.
Du hast ja auch.
Als du bei Hart aber Fair warst, auf die Frage, wie hat sich wohl Olaf Scholz
gefühlt, gesagt, interessiert nicht.
Wir reden über die Schuldenbremse. Und deshalb finde ich eigentlich diesen Habitus
jetzt von den, auch wenn ich das inhaltlich nicht teile,
sehr gut und ich würde anempfehlen, den ähnlich zu übernehmen,
dass man auch sagt, ich beantworte jetzt diese dusselige Frage nicht nur,
weil Doro Beer jetzt gerne nochmal über Gefühle sprechen will,
sondern ich rede jetzt über Mieten.
Genau. Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben. Man muss jetzt nicht auf einer Bühne
stehen und sagen, da hinten 100 Journalisten, alles meine Feinde.
Nö.
Aber der eine, der vor einem steht, da muss man einfach jetzt den Mut haben,
den Rudra-Breschmann-Moment zu fahren und zu sagen, ich breche jetzt hier eine
Sehgewohnheit, um erstens einen Überraschungsmoment herzustellen und zweitens
mit den Leuten so zu reden, wie die Leute reden.
Und dann kann man einfach sagen, wissen Sie, Herr Geis, Herr Deis, die Miete ist zu teuer.
Ich weiß, es sind 50.000 Migranten nach Passau gekommen und die kriegen wir
auch alle wieder los, aber die Miete ist trotzdem zu teuer.
Die Miete ist für 40 Millionen Deutsche zu teuer.
Das macht gar keinen Sinn. Und da muss man ihn richtig beschimpfen.
Das macht keinen Sinn, dass sie mir diese Frage stellen.
Das ist unerhört. Das ist auch frech ihrem Publikum gegenüber.
Machen sie keine Marktforschung? Also ich habe Marktforschung gemacht.
Die Miete ist zu teuer. Was soll ich ihnen sagen?
Ich rede hier mit ihnen über irgendwas, aber ich komme auf die Straße und die
Leute sagen mir, die Miete ist zu teuer. Dann muss man einfach,
die Miete ist zu teuer machen.
So, und das verstehe ich auch nicht. Also es ist einfach, Christian Lindner
macht das jetzt. Der dreht sich in die Kamera.
Ich meine, ich habe totgelacht. Ich kann es nicht zeigen, da muss ich sofort
wieder lachen. Christian Lindner hat dieses eine Video, wo er so im Bokeh-Effekt,
wo die Nase so ganz scharf und die Ohren sind schon so im Unscharfen,
wo er so zu nah dran steht.
Also der kriecht einem jetzt wirklich ins Gesicht und will einem einfach die Botschaft loswerden.
Und von daher, ja, liebe Politiker, wenn jemand sagt Millay,
dann nicht über Millay sprechen, sondern kurz Millay zitieren,
um darzustellen, wie irrsinnig das ist und die Journalisten darauf hinweisen, nein.
Cats and Dogs, Millay und Musk sind nicht die Kategorien, in der wir denken.
Bitte einfach einen Schritt weiter gehen, klüger werden, wie auch immer,
die wirklich für doof zu erklären, wenn es doof ist.
Naja, also wir wollen kurz bei Millay reinhören, wir hören nicht alle Clips,
die ich herausgesucht habe, die liegen dann einfach im Archiv für irgendwann,
wenn Christian Lindner wieder Finanzminister ist, sondern da wir uns auf den
Salon verbreiten, hören wir,
was Millay so liest.
Er geht so seine Leseliste durch. Ich will kurz dazu sagen, ich habe dieses
Interview, weil es mir selber sehr komisch vorkam, kurz GPT gegeben,
hab GPT gefragt, was fällt dir bei diesem Interview auf?
Und dann war so die Antwort, es ist sehr unausgeglichen. Also klar,
im Interview ist es so 90-10%, aber teilweise sind Millays Antworten nahezu 20 Minuten lang.
Und der Alex Friedman sitzt auch nicht bei sich in seinem Studio,
das wir kennen, sondern er ist zu ihm gereist.
Und der Millay sitzt dann in so einem 70er Jahre Sozialistensessel,
wo die Armlehne so 30 Zentimeter breit ist und so ein Scheiß.
Also es ist wirklich Das ist...
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann,
zu sagen, das ist jetzt für uns in irgendeiner Art und Weise vorbildhaft.
Das ist ja so der monologisierende Staatserklärer, der noch so eine Cyber-Synth-Idee
irgendwie hat und mit Elon Musk über auch Zivilisation und so weiter.
Also das wollen wir gar nicht alles hören.
In einem Land, das total am Boden liegt, eine Armutsquote von fast 50 Prozent.
Wie will man dieses Land mit Deutschland vergleichen?
Ja, man fragt sich auch immer, wo sind die Fake News? Also man geht so seinen Twitter durch und sagt,
ja, kommt mir alles irgendwie legit vor, aber wenn ihr im Internet lest,
GP Morgan hätte für irgendein Quartal der argentinischen Volkswirtschaft ein
8% Wirtschaftswachstumsplus errechnet, nee, ist nicht.
Also alle Legenden, die da irgendwie gestrickt werden, dass Millet irgendetwas
Erfolgreiches hinbekommt, nein, es stimmt einfach nicht.
Millet baut einfach alles ab. Also der beschreibt hier auch,
ich habe da so einen Typen, der streicht mir jeden Tag drei Gesetze aus, einfach raus.
Die gehen einfach durch. Also es ist wirklich die Kettensäge,
der ist ja mit der Kettensäge auf, das ist das Programm.
Es ist völlig inhaltsbefreit. Gut, Millet erklärt aber kurz,
was er so gelesen hat, denn er möchte sich gerne als der Kluge darstellen.
Wir hören das in einer englischen Übersetzung. Lex Friedman erklärt das am Anfang
so ganz aufwendig. Das war sehr schwer.
Er spricht natürlich seine Sprache. Es wird dann so übersetzt.
Also wir hören jetzt nicht Millet im Originalton, aber es ist sozusagen der Wortlaut auf Englisch.
I needed to spend on the taxi fare and food. And then with what I have left,
I spent all of it on more books.
And then I started to read very intensively.
And I remember, for example, the experience of reading Human Action by Mises.
And this was a book that I didn't know about.
And I remember that on the following weekend, I started to read this book right
from the first page and I didn't stop until I finished it and that was a true revolution in my head.
And having the chance to read Austrian authors like,
Rothbard, Mises, Hayek, Hoppe und Jesus Huerta de Soto oder andere wie Juan
Ramon Rallo, Philipp Bagus und Walter Bloch, zum Beispiel.
Also Ludwig von Mises hat er gelesen, was ganz interessant ist,
weil das ja ein Auto ist, mit dem sich dann auch Herbert Marcuse etwas später
auseinandersetzen wird.
Und was auch die Frankfurter Schule im Ganzen interessiert, Nämlich Ludwig von
Mises ist ja eigentlich ein Theoretiker des Liberalismus, der aber dann dort
schon sehr klar durchscheinen lässt, dass es kein Problem ist,
auch Führer mal zuzulassen.
Eine ähnliche Äußerung wird man ja dann später auch bei Hayek und Friedman finden,
wenn damit dann der Linksruck beziehungsweise der Kommunismus aufgehalten werden kann.
Und so gibt es eigentlich ein permanentes Liebäugeln des Liberalismus mit dem
Faschismus und jede Kettensäge ist eine gute Kettensäge, solange sie gegen links geht.
Ja, was kann man gegen den Führer haben? Es gibt doch mindestens einen guten
Menschen, den man auf diesen Posten bringt.
Ja und solange der die Eigentumsordnung beibehält, die Marktstrukturen weiter
ausbaut, ist am Ende egal, ob der wahnsinnig repressiv ist, ob der Frauenrechte beschneidet,
ob der sonst irgendwelche konservativen Politiken durchsetzt,
ist alles nicht so relevant, sondern der Markt ist geschützt und damit ist das immer zu begrüßen,
bevor eine linke Regierung ans Werk kommt.
Ja, freies Spiel der Kräfte. Es könnte ja die falsche Regierung sein.
Dann lieber freies Spiel der Kräfte. Er hat noch mehr Toren.
So that paved the way for me to approach the ideas of freedom.
And another book that was a very significant influence and impact on me was
the principles of political economics by Menger.
Aber er sagt doch nie so wie, sondern er zählt Namen auf und revolutionieren
die ihn so aus dem Inneren heraus.
Genau, wir können ja mal in so ein typisches Gelaber reinhören.
Im Großen und Ganzen ist das so ein, Freiheit ist ganz wichtig und es gibt nur
eine Freiheit und das ist die Freiheit vom Staat.
Also der Staat garantiert dir gar nichts und erst recht keine Freiheit,
sondern sobald der Staat abgebaut ist, ist Freiheit da.
Da würde ich jetzt sagen, ja, also auf dem Reißbrett stimmt das ja auch.
Sobald kein Polizist mehr da ist, bist du frei.
Nur die Frage ist halt immer die der Leistungsfähigkeit.
Also es gibt Gründe, warum alle immer so rätseln, was Luhmann gemeint hat mit
Komplexität muss reduziert werden, weil die zweite Seite ist immer, um sie aufzubauen.
Also im freien Spiel der Kräfte kriegst du keine Raketen gebaut und keine Kläranlage
und so weiter und die Lebenserwartung auf 80 Jahre kriegst du auch nicht gelevelt.
Das klappt nicht, indem einfach jeder das im Boxkampf entscheidet,
sondern das muss dann einfach geregelt werden. Nun gut.
Ich benutze die Definition von
Liberalismus gegeben von Alberto Venegas Linchijo, die sehr in line mit
mit der Definition von John Locke, die essentiellement die Definition von Alberto
Benegas Lynch Jr., der gesagt hat, dass Liberalismus ein unrestriktes Respekt
für das Lebensprojekt von anderen,
basiert auf das Prinzip der Nichtaggression und in der Befassung des Rechtes
zu Leben, Freiheit und Freiheit.
Also die Frage ist ja immer nicht nur, was liest man, sondern auch wie.
Wir lesen heute Sloterdijk. ich habe schon durchscheinen lassen,
ich liebe Sloderdijk-Texte.
Also das ist einfach jeder Satz ist irgendwie wichtig und inspirierend und was
auch immer. Und trotzdem werfe ich heute ihm unverzeihliche blinde Flecken und Fehler vor.
Ja, ich bin nämlich ganz überrascht, dass du das gerade sagst.
Wirst du jetzt ein konservativer, Stefan?
Naja, ich mag es ja auch inspiriert zu werden, inspirativ zu lesen.
In welche Richtung das dann geht, ich kann ja selber mitdenken.
Aber es ist kein linker Autor, das ist dir aufgefallen.
Nee, ich bin ja auch nicht, ich ordne ja eben nicht alles einer Idee unter,
bei der ich mich darüber freue.
Ah, aber auf Seite 37 hat irgendwer gesagt, der Staat kann ein Problem sein.
Also ist das ganze Buch unter dem Label, auch hier wird gesagt,
der Staat ist ein Problem.
Und dann geht er einfach von Autor zu Autor und sagt, auch der sagt das.
Und das ist wundersamerweise genau, was der auch sagt. Und alle sagen dasselbe.
Und was ist denn dasselbe? Ja, der Staat steht im Weg.
So, ja, also das kann man natürlich... Er ist halt so, und er beschreibt das
halt auch, ich bin ein Minimalist.
Also ich räume zu Hause gerne auf, ich habe nicht viel rumliegen und der Staat
muss auch so Eine Autorin muss natürlich noch unterkommen.
There is a moment when they do an interview with Milton Friedman and they ask him about liberals.
And then he says that there are three types of liberals.
There are the classical liberals, where, for example, Adam Smith or Milton Friedman himself could fit.
Some say that Hayek could fit into that category.
For me, Hayek is a minarchist.
Then you have the minarchist where you could clearly find in that place Mises Hayek.
Ich frage mich dann immer, okay, wir gucken hier auf eine Schule,
in der sind 1400 Schüler und die müssen alle irgendwann mal einen Abschluss schreiben.
Niemand von denen bekäme auch nur irgendeinen, also man würde die aus dem Raum
jagen, wenn die so da säßen.
Was Trump, Milley, Scholz, Merz, die ganzen Staatschefs jetzt so abliefern, das geht einfach nicht.
Es ist katastrophal. Wir haben es ja gesehen. Scholz mit Lea Ippi.
Sie macht philosophische Vorschläge. Er geht nicht darauf ein.
Elon Musk fabuliert wirklich dotternd irgendetwas in die Ferne hinein.
Man weiß gar nicht, wo er hin will, aber er sagt sich, ich bin Elon Musk,
ich kann das machen, die Leute werden mir trotzdem zuhören.
Und das ist genau dieser Gestus, den wir hier vorfinden.
Also Miele's Denken ist ganz einfach. Er sagt, ich bin ein Minimalist und da
es aber immer noch so Reste vom Staat gibt, gilt dort ein Nullsummenspiel der
Macht und es darf niemals an die Linken fallen.
Punkt. Das ist die ganze Logik. Mehr ist es nicht.
Er will einen Nachtwächterstaat. Das ist der Staat, in dem nur noch darauf Acht
gegeben wird, dass das Eigentum da ist und dass die Marktwirtschaft sich weiter
ausbreiten kann und zwar in alle Bereiche.
Selbst der Nachtwächter ist so ein bisschen, also als Figur sozusagen,
ist noch so ein bisschen, ah, kann man den nicht auch noch so.
Den muss man natürlich selbst in der Hand haben.
Genau, wenn das eine private Kraft ist.
Polizei und Militär.
Ja, genau. So, wir hören noch einen Clip, wo ich mir einfach noch denke,
Leute, wenn ihr hört, dass irgendwer in Deutschland sagt, Milley und Musk sind die Vorbilder.
Von Musk haben wir schon gehört, er möchte irgendwie zehnmal so viele Menschen
auf der Welt, um den Scope of Consciousness, also,
das Reich des Bewusstseins so zu erweitern, dass wir die zentralen Probleme
lösen, wo man sich denkt, zehnmal mehr Menschen auf der Welt,
ist das nicht vielleicht die Ursache der Probleme und so weiter.
Und bei Milley schlägt sich das jetzt so nieder, Er versucht uns jetzt hier irgendwas zu erklären.
Ich sage euch nur, es geht tatsächlich um einen Tisch und er versucht in diesem
minimalistischen Nullsummen-Machtspiel,
in dem niemand irgendetwas gewinnt und falls jemand Macht hat,
ist es immer zu viel und die Linken dürfen niemals Macht haben,
weil dann wäre das zu viel und so.
Niemand hat Macht und alles freigekriegt. Also der totale Reduktionismus.
Und irgendwo fehlt eigentlich noch so ein bisschen Pragmatismus.
Er versucht jetzt mal uns zu erklären, wie er so sein pragmatisches Denken verankert.
Also es geht um einen Tisch.
Was man muss verstehen, ist etwas, was die Städte-Konditionen.
Wir sagen, dass man nicht rectangularer Tables mag. Man mag zirkulare Tables.
Die Realität ist, I have only a few hours until I go and catch my flight.
And the table is rectangular. You like a circular table, a round one, but there isn't one.
What you have is a rectangular table.
So either we do the interview here or we just can't do it. So what do you do?
You adapt to the current conditions.
Ja, großartig.
Also da ist ein eckiger Tisch, aber du willst einen Runden.
Und dann sagen die dir, dein Flug geht aber gleich, wir schaffen es nicht noch
rechtzeitig, einen eckigen Tisch herzustellen. den können sie auch den Runden nehmen.
Dann ist die große Lebensweisheit von Javier Milley.
Dann musst du dich anpassen an die Situation und dich an den Rundentisch setzen.
Ja.
Wirklich, das ist...
Wahnsinn.
Wenn Christian Lindner sowas sagt, muss einfach in Deutschland... Sorry, wir sind...
Man muss dann einfach loslachen. Man muss sich einfach kaputtlachen.
Wir sind Land der Dichter und Denker.
Ja.
Nee. Also das geht einfach nicht.
Also dieses Gespräch, ich nenne nur die Themen. Aber die Armutsraten steigen doch in Argentinien.
Nein, das waren sie vorher auch, aber wir haben jetzt den illegal machenden
Staat, der das verdeckt und so weiter weggezogen und die Tischdecke weggezogen
und jetzt ist halt die von uns geerbte Armut da. Aber sie wächst aber nicht.
Wir lieben das X-Network, denn dort können wir sagen, was wir wollen.
Denn alle Journalisten sind Sozialisten. Woran erkennen wir das?
Sobald sie Kritik bekommen, fangen sie an zu weinen. Das ist das Argument.
Also man kann es einfach, das geht einfach nicht in Deutschland.
Wenn Christian Lindner sagt, ein bisschen mehr Millet wagen,
muss man einfach wirklich lachen.
Hast du jetzt gesagt, Ich würde sagen, einfach abwinken und sagen, sorry, aber.
Ja, man muss sie, man muss, doch, ich finde, man muss sie einfach lächerlich machen.
Ich hatte kürzlich ein Erlebnis, ich fuhr im Auto und hörte Radio und dort war
eine kurze Berichterstattung darüber,
dass die Junge Union in Hamburg sich getroffen hat und dort tagte.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hattest.
Und dort gab es einen Vorschlag von der Jungen Union,
dass man jetzt die Autobahnen ausbaut und ich dachte noch so,
naja, ich bin durchaus dafür, dass man wohl an manchen Teilen in Deutschland
mal darüber nachdenken muss, ob man einen Ausbau braucht.
Ich bin ja da bekanntermaßen unorthodox unterwegs, aber die Argumentation war nun die folgende.
Momentan braucht man von Hamburg nach München fünf oder sechs Stunden mit dem Auto,
nein acht Stunden mit dem Auto und wenn man die Autobahn ausbauen würde,
dann könnte man 200 fahren.
Wenn man 200 kmh fährt von Hamburg nach München, dann ist man in viereinhalb Stunden da.
Und das wurde aber in diesem Bericht, und das war das Interessante,
das war einfach Nachrichten, es wurde wie eine normale Nachricht präsentiert.
Und man muss dann eigentlich loslachen, man kann ja sagen, es gibt hier einen Vorschlag,
stellen Sie sich vor, Sie fahren von Hamburg nach Münzen 200 kmh durchgehend,
dann sind Sie schon in viereinhalb Stunden da und dann muss man einfach loslachen,
aber das wurde in einer Ernsthaftigkeit vorgetragen,
als sei das jetzt ein ganz seriöser Vorschlag und ich glaube,
das müsste man sich eigentlich jetzt angewöhnen, dass man sich über die unseriösen
Vorschläge auch lustig macht.
Dann bin ich sogar für Hyperloop. dann lass Ile, mach's den Tunnel bauen,
nee, das ist wirklich alles schräg, das geht einfach nicht gut.
Ich würde vorschlagen wir gehen doch jetzt zum Salon über wir sprechen über weil du hast wieder.
OMR Podcast gehört.
Das machen wir mal noch irgendwann Peter Sloterdijk hat ein Buch geschrieben,
das heißt Der Kontinent ohne Eigenschaften Lesezeichen im Buch Europa bei Surkamp
ist es erschienen er fragt sich also,
was Zeichnet Europa aus,
hat Europa tatsächlich keine Eigenschaften.
Es ist ein Buch, das sich sehr kritisch mit dem Postkolonialismus auseinandersetzt,
um das vorsichtig zu sagen.
Er verwirft eigentlich den Postkolonialismus. Ich finde dieses Buch auch wahnsinnig
inspirierend, in der Hinsicht auch, dass er jemand ist, der unglaublich belesen
ist und dann aber auch die richtigen Texte findet,
um zumindest seine Theorien deutlich zu machen.
Es ist ein beeindruckendes Buch, das man sehr gründlich lesen muss, um es zu verstehen.
Langsam vor allem.
Man muss es langsam lesen, da ist nichts mit doppelter Geschwindigkeit.
Ich hoffe jetzt die Clips, die wir gehört haben, waren auch wieder ein einfacher.
Sorry, genau. Wenn ihr mich darauf hinweist, bitte macht das doch nicht mit
den Eklipsen höherer Geschwindigkeit.
Also wir sind nicht das CDF. Bei uns sitzt nicht eine riesige Redaktion und
es gab keine Redaktionskonferenz, wo wir entschieden haben, wir spielen den Clip schneller.
Sondern ich habe die einfach aus Versehen schneller exportiert,
weil Ultraschall, dieser Software, die wir alle benutzen und über die wir sehr
dankbar sind, fehlt ein kleines Ding,
nämlich, dass man, wenn man im Arbeitsmodus ist und die Clips herstellt,
danach einfach sagt, aber du weißt, ich exportiere die jetzt,
du kannst sie wieder auf einfache Geschwindigkeit runter. Nein,
das muss man nochmal selber machen.
Deswegen waren die in anderthalb Fahrergeschwindigkeit.
Ja, es waren also ein paar Clips in englischsprachiger, ich glaube von Scott
Galloway und noch ein paar andere waren etwas schneller.
Das soll nicht wieder vorkommen. Wir sprechen noch über andere Bücher,
beziehungsweise stellen ja noch Texte jeder vor. Ich habe einen Roman aus Brasilien,
der sehr beeindruckt ist von einem Autor, der keine 30 Jahre alt geworden ist.
Das Buch ist jetzt auf deutscher Schienen. Dann habe ich mich nochmal mit AI
auseinandergesetzt und zwar mit dem Buch von Kate Crawford, das nun auf deutscher
Schienen ist, Atlas der KI, die materielle Wahrheit hinter den neuen Datenimperien.
Ich will da aber ein Kapitel draus vorstellen, nicht das ganze Buch,
so viel Zeit haben wir nicht, aber ein Kapitel, da geht es nämlich um die Erkennung von Emotionen.
Dann haben wir im letzten Podcast darüber gesprochen, dass wir es mit zunehmenden
Klagewellen zu tun haben, wenn Politiker oder andere Leute aus den Medien beleidigt werden.
Im Spiegel gab es dazu einen Artikel, es gibt ein Startup, das sich darum kümmert
und zu diesem Startup gehört auch eine Juli-Vorsitzende, die das mitgegründet
hat. Ganz interessant, ganz richtig.
Dann werde ich noch einen Artikel vorstellen über die Filmindustrie,
denn inzwischen kann es für Filmstudios lohnend sein,
Filme fertig zu drehen, sie nicht zu veröffentlichen und sie zu schreddern und dann bekommt man Geld,
weil man es abschreiben kann als Film.
Fail-Projekt. Ganz interessant. Also ein Film, auf den viele warten,
kommt nicht in die Kinos.
Wie heißt er?
Werde ich dann sagen.
Ja, krass.
Und ich werde noch vorstellen eine unglaublich beeindruckende Einspielung von
Faurés Klavier-Gesamtwerk von einem der interessantesten Pianisten unserer Zeit.
Okay, sehr gut. Gesamtwerk. Wie viele CDs sind da drin?
Vier.
Isabella Weber hat in Jakobin einen Text, ein Interview mit der Überschrift,
so geht antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik.
Wir lesen uns das durch, nicken die ganze Zeit, sagen, das ist richtig,
aber der Name geht nicht.
Der Name geht nicht, ich will es ganz deutlich sagen.
Kommt auch im Text nicht vor. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das geschah,
aber dazu passend, wir gehen kurz in diese Zahlen von der New York Times zum
Thema, die Präsidentschaftswahl in Amerika ist jetzt ausgezählt.
Ist typischerweise kein Salonthema, weil ein nachhaltlicher Text.
Aber ich will kurz die Stellen vorlesen, die uns zeigen, was es bedeutet,
wenn man als Kandidatin antritt und sagt, ich bin einfach nur die antifaschistische Kandidatin.
Das geht nämlich nicht gut aus.
Gar nicht gut. Von daher ist, nee, wir brauchen keine antifaschistische Wirtschaftspolitik,
sondern wir brauchen einen anderen Namen für diese richtige Wirtschaftspolitik.
Livia Gerster hat in der FAZ eine ganze Seite, weil kürzer ging es nicht,
zu den Fauxpas von Friedrich Merz gegenüber Frauen gemacht. Das ist so irre.
Also man kann es sich nicht vorstellen, die sagt, man darf eigentlich nicht
Kanzler werden, aber wird es natürlich doch.
Und in Kommunikation und Recht war ein junger Anwalt, unser Alter, mein Alter.
Der über das Verbot von Phasers, Verbot von, weil es hat zum einen Präzedenzcharakter,
denn auch dieses links unten in die Mediadinges,
Ist nicht da auf Augenhöhe, sondern wir haben jetzt das erste Mal ein Vereinsverbot
gegen Medienfreiheit und so.
Sache vom Bundesverfassungsgericht und da ist ein letzter Absatz drin,
der ist so krass, den müssen wir mal vorlesen einfach.
Okay.
Zur Frage Freiheit der Medien und was bedeutet eigentlich Demokratie.
Wir werden im Salon auch nochmal die Termine nennen für die Live-Salons im nächsten Jahr.
Ich glaube der erste Salon im März ist schon ausverkauft.
Es gibt aber dann drei weitere Termine noch für Juni, September, Dezember 25.
Da werden wir nochmal die Termine nennen. Außerdem will ich noch darauf hinweisen,
auch wenn das dann schon morgen oder heute ist, je nachdem wann die Leute das hören.
Ich bin am 7.12. in Hannover im Pavillon zu Gast. Wer da kommen möchte,
da gibt es glaube ich noch Karten.
Glühwein?
Nein, Glühwein gibt es da auf keinen Fall. Und dann möchte ich noch darauf hinweisen,
dass man diesen Salon auch jetzt verschenken kann.
Nicht nur zur Weihnachtszeit, aber jetzt besonders vielleicht.
Also wer jemandem Inhalte schenken möchte und vielleicht Inspirationen für gute
Bücher, kann den Salon verschenken. Das ist ganz einfach möglich.
Bei Steady ist eingeblendet, dass es da Geschenkpakete gibt und die kann man
dann anklicken und das aktivieren und dann kann derjenige für ein Jahr den Salon hören. Genau.
Wenn ihr das macht, ihr schickt einfach, also ihr schickt Vorname,
Nachname, E-Mail-Adresse und dann kriegt ihr das als Geschenklieferung.
Ja.
Man hat sich dann Account by Steady klicken und hat einfach ein Jahr schon Salon drin.
Ich will es nochmal auch labeln als nicht nur in Sachen von Geschenk,
man beschenkt sich damit auch selbst.
Denn ich stelle doch immer wieder fest, wie erlöst Menschen sind,
die unseren Podcast hören, dass sie mal mit uns in Kontakt kommen können,
weil sie dann so eine Art endlich vernünftige Leute, endlich normale Leute,
wie auch immer, die wissen Bescheid, ich kann jetzt hier mal.
Und das wäre doch gut, wenn man einen Freundeskreis hat, in dem man einfach
mal sagen kann, was Sache ist, nämlich das ist alles bescheuert.
Und zwar nicht einfach nur bescheuert im Sinne von bescheuert,
sondern es gibt da sehr gute Argumente und man kann sich gemeinsam drüber lustig machen.
Und vielleicht auch vertiefende Austauschen, das habe ich jetzt auch erlebt,
als ich in Zürich zu Gast war.
Dort waren auch einige, die unseren Podcast hören, die dann danach gleich miteinander
ins Gespräch kommen konnten, obwohl sie sich nicht kannten, aber über den Podcast
kennt man sich dann quasi doch.
Also diese Möglichkeit gibt es und auch sonst lohnt sich der Salon in diesem
Monat doppelt, weil es ja noch den Live-Salon dann gibt.
Vor Weihnachten werden wir den in der Case aufzeichnen und dann auch schnell
veröffentlichen. Wer also jetzt den Salon hören will, kann das wie gesagt über Steady tun.
Das ist auch die präferierte Plattform von uns.
Außerdem sind wir noch bei Patreon und über Apple ist es auch ganz bequem buchbar
für die Leute, die ohnehin alles über Apple machen.
Das ist also alles auch dann nochmal einsehbar auf der Seite neue20er.de.
Und dann würde ich sagen, gehen wir doch jetzt hinein zu Peter Sloterdijk.
Ins Buch Europas.
Und setzen mal unsere Lesezeichen.
So ist es, bis gleich.